in the simplomatic Sao Paulo Eatery A
couple of regulars discuss Sunday
night's election results like many
Brazilians Lucio says he's in shock
there isn't a right wing anymore it's an
extreme right wing a radicalization and
the same on the left I think it's a
global Trend we've seen it in Italy and
many other countries and unfortunately
this polarization is leaving us obliged
to choose between extremes
voters gave hard-line conservative
candidates to Congress the Senate and
governors an unprecedented boost
practically eliminating Brazil's
political center right
incumbent president Jade bolsonaro may
have come in a close second in the first
round of the presidential race but his
once weak political party was hands down
the winner of the national elections
defying all predictions and that's no
small feat
an example bolsonaro's former
environmental Minister Ricardo Salas was
elected to congress during the pandemic
he was recorded telling a cabinet
meeting that the health emergency would
serve as an excellent distraction for
cattle Farmers to overrun the Amazon
rainforest another person is tamares
Alves a hardcore conservative who
opposes Progressive women's rights and
has been elected Senator
it's up to the people to choose who they
identify with they were the candidates
who represent bolsonaro's policies
all this marks a major shift I think
what's happening in Brazil since before
the election is that the environments
the the political environment in Brazil
the Zeitgeist of Brazil we can say that
is conservative
we are in a conservative country Lula is
an exception
Lula is of course the former left-wing
president who scored 48 of the votes in
the presidential race and will face
bolsonaro again in a runoff later this
month but winning won't be easy
bolsonaro has a huge advantage over his
rival as president he can address his
compatriots anytime he wants on
television or on radio and he also has
access to the executive checkbook which
as he's already suggested he will
continue to use to help offset the
impact of inflation
he's wasting no time Monday the
government announced it was bringing
forward a welfare payment due at the end
of the month and a second one five days
before the runoff
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Sao Paulo